la langue par nature si on ne veut pas
que les gens soient à disposition des
marchands de sommeil pour reconnaître
leurs droits pour faire appliquer leurs
droits pour puiss puisse effuellement
lire leur contrat de travail ou pouvoir
avoir un minimum de discussion en
société me paraît assez
[Musique]
normal le parcours d'intégration de la
personne qui est dans son pays d'origine
qui sera admise au regroupement familial
que le parcours d'intégration commence
dans son pays d'origine avec les moyen
que les Alliances françaises pourront
mettre en place les offi bon ça veut
dire que il n'y a pas de test qui
interdit à ce seul prétexte évidemment
encore une fois nous ne le pouvons pas
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme laalinéa 10 du préembule de 1946
que nous avons cité il y a quelques
instants nous l'interdirons donc ça
n'est pas une condition générale et
absolue ça n'est pas un test qui serait
établi dans les pays d'origine ça n'est
pas une obligation de résultat c'est un
simple une simple obligation de moyens
la réalité c'est que pendant des années
les personnes qui nous ont qu'on a
accueilli sur notre territoire ont étit
parfois abandonnés je prends l'exemple
volontaire de ma grand-mère qui était
grand-mère espagnole donc avec une
langue plutôt facile et on en parle
depuis tout à l'heure la majorité des
personnes qui demandent le regroupement
familial aujourd'hui ont une procédure
entre 18 et 24 mois ce qui laisse le
temps à quelqu'un de pouvoir se former
sur un minimum requis en langue
française la langue la maîtrise de la
langue française est vraiment la
première condition d'intégration des
étrangers donc il faut tout faire il
faut tout faire pour
l'encourager je voudrais vous faire part
d'une réalité que je connais bien parce
que comme maire de ma commune pendant
plus de 10 ans j'ai mis en place des
formations de français langue étrangère
et je crois il y a beaucoup de
résistance de la part de
certaines personnes à vouloir maîtriser
un minimum de langue française c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut à avant
l'arrivée sur le territoire national
exiger un minimum connaissez-vous une
seule personne qui souhaite ne pas être
comprise quand elle va faire les courses
au supermarché dans notre pays
connaissez-vous une seule personne qui
souhaite que ses enfants ne soient pas
compris dans la cour de récréation
connaissez-vous une seule personne qui
aspirant à vivre sur notre territoire
souhaite ne pas parler notre langue je
n'en ai jamais rencontré aucune